pink slime you know about pink slime
we've talked a lot about pink slime it
is making its way back for a series of
reasons let's look at what pink slime
looks like first so this is what actual
pink slime and if you haven't seen our
videos on pink slime I highly recommend
you just google or will annotate to our
old pink slime video so this is what
pink slime looks like and basically what
pink slime is is just the awful pieces
of the meat because they want the
cheapest piece the pieces that literally
like are falling off the bone that are
all gross and disgusting
and then they Jam them together they run
them through ammonia to get all the
bacteria off it's a pretty awful
situation we'll get to more about that
in a second now let's look at the
picture for that everyone thinks of pink
slime so this is the rumored picture of
what pink slime really looks like so the
other one is what it does look like this
is the rumored picture of what it may
look like in like an earlier State or
something like that and now let's look
at a little bit of the background story
on pink slimes demise in 2012 ABC news
and celebrity chef jamie oliver exposed
the low-cost meat product pink slime
McDonald's and Taco Bell were announced
it in public schools around the country
stopped serving it by May 2012 beef
products Inc the inventor of the product
was on the brink of collapse closing
three of its four plants and laying off
700 people but in August BPI reopened
one of its closed plants then a little
bit more for you this is from Dan Hale
who's an animal science professor at
Texas A&M he said the main issue is the
drought a lot of the us especially the
parts that raise cattle have experienced
the severe drought and those animals are
no longer available for producing calves
that we can in turn generate for beef
trimmings so a lot of the global warming
people are gonna say there's some issues
there cuz you know the cow farts are
also creating methane and then that eats
up the world Matt so you know about that
your our cow fart guy yeah so we there's
a series of problems here pink slime of
course is cheaper the one you make this
meat it's a lot cheaper because you're
getting those crappy little extra pieces
instead of the good cuts the science is
inconclusive as far as I can tell
whether this is actually worse for you
once it eat it people say it's not going
to kill you the
eating something that's been washing
ammonia seems kind of disgusting to me
but this is one of the stories where all
the science people start yelling at me
because it seems inconclusive can you
clean up anything of what I just said
because I know you know a bit of that
well I think that first of all it sounds
disgusting it is true that your body
generates a small amount of ammonia but
that's what you excrete in your urine so
it's a waste product in the body and
yeah the meat that they use is is from
parts that I think are like closer to
the surface or something and so they're
very you know likely contaminated with
things like e.coli and stuff it's a
really gross
thing but then again how do you how do
you get a burger for 80 cents without
using you know meat that's questionable
right so that's what so it's a couple
things that are happening here partly
they're having they we have less access
to the animals because of the drought
and other climate related things then on
top of that we've a bad economy so
people don't want to spend as much so
you want an 80 cents hamburger well then
that's how you're gonna get it that way
is this story just like the story to me
is like everything that which is why we
talk about it all the time because it's
like about the gross food that we eat
it's about the economic disaster we're
in it's about the earth it's al it's a
little something for everybody
you think my question is if you're at
the grocery store does it say it on the
packaging or all those is that set on
the pack so they don't have to they
don't have to we did a story a couple
weeks ago how even the phrase
all-natural
actually means nothing it's on
everything all the time all-natural but
no they don't have to say it so for
example if you were to get Trader Joe's
just like ground beef from Trader Joe's
technically they could be using the pink
slime this ammonia thing they I did a
little googling they don't do it so that
is I'm still okay getting my meat there
but yeah you don't know and that's the
so is that a bigger part of the problem
too that we don't package things
correctly and we and our labeling and
all that yeah I mean I know that there's
efforts underway and I don't know where
they currently stand to get GMO products
labeled Amanda you know mandatorily is
that a word yeah so yeah I make them do
it yes and I think that would be
definitely
very helpful as far as this pink slime
stuff goes because it's gross it's
definitely not something I want to
consume yeah all right so for the people
that say though the the lower economic
and spectrum that those people need
options why is it that we can't make
healthy food cheaper that's what I think
all the time like it seems to me all the
processed stuff and all there it goes
through so many different things to
become what it is in that frozen package
like that should be more expensive
rather than the stuff that just pops out
of the earth and you eat it and yet for
some reason that's reverse what do we do
so that people that can't afford this
stuff can eat healthier all I can say is
I do think it should be on packaging I
think it should not in any sense be
served to schoolchildren
at all because they're gonna have it in
their system for the longest you know I
think that's not correct and I don't
know what the answer is I mean I think
we have to be more responsible as a
society in understanding when they add
the food chain herbs and flows that we
have to kind of go with it you know we
get enough protein in our diets you know
as far as other things that we consume
and and I don't know what the answer is
as far as poverty people that are
underserved how they go about it I don't
know what the answer should be the
answer partly is that we need to show
some of the like if we could get a real
expose on how this stuff is done because
it's hard to get video of it of the
actual process which is why we don't
have video to show you guys right now
like yeah I think I think education
plays a huge role in it and it's you
know some people I was actually on the
episode when when McDonald's voluntarily
when they removed the yeah and I I think
that it's always an educational issue
you know I think that the more people
can understand how unhealthy this stuff
is for you they would then opt for maybe
the more expensive products which would
you know demand obviously would bring
the price down but in the end you know
whether or not you're spending more at
the checkout at your supermarket I mean
it's going to alleviate healthcare costs
down the road I mean if you think that
like
fed meat is expensive look at cancer man
it's like a really expensive thing
cardiovascular disease that's chronic
disease is like the most expensive thing
so I think education I think that there
that there needs to be what you know
what you were seeing a big s was that
education is the right answer
hearing you say that because then I
think about my children my children
learn how to do PowerPoint in seventh
grade you know what why not take that
off the table and teach them how to read
labels yeah instead of focusing on
technology technology technology how
about some base stuff you know that they
can understand even boys who don't do a
lot of at men I mean they do shop and
I'm saying generally in families it's
not the man who shops everything but it
should be overall education towards our
children of what you're eating and what
a diet should consist of that's more
than what they're giving now because
everyone wants everyone to be on the
Internet